the United States government 250 years
ago there was never the intention for it
to go up in population by an order of
magnitude and for the government to get
so bloated and for the wealth inequality
to get so drastic and for there to be
such a obliteration of the ethos of the
Constitution and for there to be a
disregard for the humanness uh of the
working class there's an absolute
disregard for it there is a total uh
separation that's happened in the West
where instead of the way that trees and
mushrooms exchange nutrients with each
other underground in Perfect Harmony as
nature where humans can biomimic that
it's become complete separate silos of
billionaires and corporate CEOs
and deep State Elites and all kinds of
all kinds of and all
kinds of hoarding and it's time
to call it out the way it is it's time
to build the new and it's time to create
the Catalyst that wake those that are in
those positions of wealth in those silos
because they can come on to the new
earth side and create a Big Splash in in
that direction